[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu viertel nach acht ist ein sehr
besonderer tag hier in diesem studio
genau dort neben mir stand vor gut einer
stunde boxlegende wladimir klitschko der
seit wochen gemeinsam mit seinem bruder
vitali für das schicksal der ukraine
kämpft es ist der kampf seines lebens
und im interview mit vertrieb sehr
platil und teilweise hat er deutschland
eindringlich um hilfe gebeten der satz
der mich persönlich am meisten berührt
hat wir sind nicht zu stoppen außerdem
müssen alle gequält werden alle wir sind
mit unserem willen stärker als die
waffen oder einer der stärksten armeen
der welt aber alles hat ein limit ich
will dass unsere verbündeten diesen
krieg beenden insbesondere interview
vladimir klitschko und vier weitere
spannende thesen möchte ich mit meinen
gästen diskutieren heute mit von der
partie ex regierungssprecher und
kommunikationsberater nummer eins béla
anda bild moderatorin patricia plat cdu
urgestein und der kanzler der herzen
wolfgang boss bei der uns zugeschaltet
ist fdp politiker sebastian czaja und
bild sportmoderatorin valentina maceri
patricia lasst uns doch direkt mit dir
beginnen du hast heute das emotionale
interview mit wladimir klitschko geführt
welcher satz ist denn bei dir am meisten
hängen geblieben das sind so viele sätze
denn es war ein interview das mich ganz
tief berührt hat es ist ein mensch der
mitten aus dem krieg zu uns kam ein satz
der mir im objekt ist wir haben keine
zeit mehr
wenn wir hier sprechen wird weiter
angegriffen prasseln weiter die bomben
auf mein land sagte er und genau das hat
uns dann auch paul ronzheimer mit im
gespräch bestätigt zugeschaltet aus kiew
der sagte ich muss hier mal kurz sagen
ich weiß ihr bis gehört hat aber hier
hinter mir ein großer anschlag gerade zu
hören also dieser mann der sich auf
gemachte themen das grauen dieses
krieges auch im gesicht geschrieben
stand es war hier so leise im studio wie
ich das noch nie in meinem leben erlebt
hat man hat jedem wort gelauscht all den
schilderungen gelauscht er uns
mitgebracht hat und dieser brutale krieg
dessen bilder wir hier ja gerade
journalisten jeden tag sehen es damit so
viel näher gerückt und hat so viel mehr
noch das herz berührt das leid der
menschen dort wurde so eigen dringlich
noch einmal sichtbar und eben auch
fühlbar durch dieses interview
bela du hast bestimmt auch reingeschaut
in das interview vladimir klitschko wie
sind deine empfindungen also dass dieses
interview dass das hat glaube ich jeden
der es gesehen hat unglaublich berührt
der satz es gab viele sätze das war ja
ich weiß nicht ob man das sagen darf
aber es war ja war ja eine unglaubliche
wortgewalt die da von ihm ausging und
ich habe mich in kurzen moment gefragt
wie wie also da ist deutsch eine art
fremdsprache für ihn aber trotzdem ist
war ja unglaublich poetisch auch in all
den darstellungen auch aber auch
unglaublich klar und präzise und das hat
mich sehr
beeindruckt aber was mich besonders
berührt hat war der satz unsere kinder
haben keine zukunft also
und wir sehen ja hier das ja nicht mal
zwei kilometer weit entfernt von hier
der hauptbahnhof wo immer noch tausende
jeden tag ankommen bevor sie dann nach
deutschland weiter verteilt werden
entsprechend dann auch und manchmal gehe
ich der abends tatsächlich vorbei denn
die stehen in den bussen dann sind dann
die die die jungen meistens mitte mit
ihren jungen kindern gleich natürlich
froh hier zu sein das liegt man aber
auch natürlich voller schrecken vor dem
was sie da erlebt haben also da kann man
nur sagen wirklich gut ab auch vor
dieser reise um hier nochmal das
bewusstsein zu schärfen was jetzt
passieren muss und das sheraton im
interview schilderte dass leute mir auch
noch mal ganz eindringlich denn er sagte
natürlich ist er dankbar dass wir diesen
kindern den müttern den menschen die
dort ankommen helfen aber natürlich
wollen wir kinder nur eins nach hause
und deren natürlich bis heute nicht
verstanden die kann das auch überhaupt
gar nicht verstehen dass es dieses
zuhause nicht mehr gibt dass es dieses
jahr diesen alltag den sie hatten mit
freunden draußen sein in die schule
gehen draußen zu spielen dass es mit
einem mal vorbei ist das können diese
kinder die schreckliches erleben
schreckliches sehen er hat dort ganz
eindringlich auch geschildert von einem
jungen mit dem er gesprochen hat er ist
14 jahre alt ist und der erleben musste
wie sein vater erschossen wurde vor
seinen augen der erleben musste wie auf
ihn selbst geschossen wurde der dann am
boden lag mehrfach getroffen und die
hosen ging offenbar davon aus dass ihnen
auch an kopf getroffen haben das haben
sie aber sie hat einen hoch und deswegen
sind sie weiter gegangen weil sie
dachten dieses kind ist tot und mit
diesem jungen hat er gesprochen und er
sagte dieser junge wird nie wieder
derselbe sein er wird nie wieder das
kind sein dass er einmal war und dass
man die schilderungen auch die mich
besonders berührt haben ohne diesen
jungen zu kennen ohne ein gesicht vor
augen zu haben finde ich ist das etwas
das das herz so so tief berührt und das
ist ja nur ein schicksal von einem
menschen die gerade dieses schicksal ein
absolut und ich mir hätte es total
berührt also als vater einer tochter
fünf jahre zwei flugstunden von hier
passiert genau das was gerade
beschrieben wurde von wladimir klitschko
und das zeigt dass es
in europa passiert das ist vor unserer
haustür dass es bei uns passiert und
wenn man sich überlegt dass wir
auch von ihm noch mal sehr deutlich
aufgefordert wurden hier nicht nur hin
zu schauen sondern auch zu handeln dann
war das ein sehr sehr eindringlicher
appell und noch mal sehr deutlich zu
machen auch das ist etwas ist was uns
alle auch hier in berlin gerade mit
blick auf diese geteilte stadt noch
einmal zu vergegenwärtigen und deutlich
zu machen nicht er ist der held sondern
die heldinnen und helden sind die die
das zuhause der kinder der familie
verteidigen die journalisten die vor ort
darüber berichten es gibt so viele
gesichter von helden das war für mich
der beeindruckte moment als das noch mal
deutlich gemacht hat was ich auch sehr
stark fand an der stelle die wortwahl
klar wie du schon gesagt dass bilder und
vor allem aber auch die art und weise
wie er das gesagt hat er hat die dinge
ganz klar formuliert er hat aber nicht
nur mit dem finger auf andere gezeigt
sondern er hat sich auch dankbar gezeigt
und das ist in einer solch extremen
situation finde ich nicht immer
selbstverständlich
also für mich hat er auch so gewirkt
aber trotz allem noch einen klaren kopf
haut und genau weiß was zu tun ist und
vor allem was er auch hat und das kommt
natürlich auch aus seiner sportler zeit
er hat ein kämpferherz genauso wie sein
bruder und das ist glaube ich in solchen
situationen ganz ganz wichtig niemals
aufzugeben dankbar zu sein für das was
man noch hart dankbar zu sein für
diejenigen die helfen und aber klar zu
formulieren was man noch braucht und das
war eben so da weise fast schon
unangenehm er sagte irgendwann wir
wollen nicht immer nur fordern und
fordern erwirkte dann fast bescheiden
mit dieser bitte sei dem land zu helfen
nicht nur mit humanitärer hilfe auch mit
waffen wir haben auch über einen
möglichen
exportstopp importstopp gesprochen dass
wir uns endlich diese abhängigkeit der
russischen energie beenden und er war in
dieser forderung dennoch weiter so
höflich ob er wohl wenn man an diesem
gespräch teilgenommen hat man selbst
sich fast geschämt hat wenn man gefühlt
hat wie können wir das machen wie können
wir all diese menschen im stich lassen
wie können wir auf die wirtschaft und
die folgen jetzt in dieser sekunde
schauen wo wir solche schilderungen hier
würde ich gerne einmal hemsbach rhein im
airbus passieren und zugeschaltet schön
dass sie heute abend mit dabei sind
meine frage ist an sie natürlich müssen
wir uns schämen
jedenfalls müssen wir uns fragen ob wir
nicht einen verhängnisvollen hang zur
besserwisserei haben wir neigen ja dazu
die ukraine zu erklären was richtig ist
und was nicht richtig ist oder was man
an ihrer stelle besser tun sollte wir
waren im geleitzug der europäer er die
bremse uns dass wir in der lokomotive
gesessen haben dann schreiben müssen wir
uns nicht aber wir müssen uns schon
selbst kreativ fragen ob wir das getan
haben was wir hätten tun müssen und ob
wir jetzt im moment das tun was
notwendig ist bei dem frage bei der
frage des importstopps für gas und öl
bin ich etwas vorsichtiger wenn wir
jetzt sagt dass es stimmt in der sache
stimmt es ja durch den bezug dieser
rohstoffe finanzieren wir jedenfalls
mittelbar den krieg profis das stimmt
aber ich möchte dann gerne wissen wo
bekommen wir dann diese rohstoffe heer
von wem in welcher menge zu welchen
preisen und wenn wissen nicht bekommen
was für auswirkungen
das ich habe in den letzten tagen
mehrfach
gelesen auch von repräsentanten meiner
partei anders leute die ein
überdurchschnittlich hohes einkommen
haben gut fünfstellig
hohe pensionen bekommen oder bekommen
werden dass sie aufrufen ein bisschen
den gürtel enger zu schnallen wir
müssten bescheidener werden und und und
wir müssen uns mal in die situation von
leuten versetzen da ist schon der gürtel
auf dem letzten loch die könntest nicht
noch enger schnallen und ich möchte das
gerne dass diejenigen die politische
verantwortung tragen genau sagen was sie
meinen und mit ihren forderungen nicht
im dubiosen leuten
erzählt er sich findet diese forderungen
teile ich absolut wir müssen für
irgendeinen plan am ich habe derzeit
aber irgendwie den eindruck sollte putin
uns jetzt ganz schnell den gashahn
zudrehen dann haben wir den notfallplan
erstmals erarbeitet worden wir haben ja
die erste stufe bereits ausgerufen dann
haben wir was vorliegen aber von selber
die initiative das voran zum beispiel
patricia bei notfallplänen und so weiter
ich würde natürlich erstmal der
industrie der strom abgestellt werden
und jetzt aufgrund der energiepreise
passiert ist schon das
produktionsstätten nicht mehr alle
maschinen am laufen haben also schon
jetzt ist es nicht so als würde in der
industrie schon gar kein energieproblem
da sein wer hat noch nicht mal hinter
uns und das hat ja überall spuren
hinterlassen ich glaube nur wir müssen
wir uns dieses problem jetzt stellen und
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt an diesen
lösungen arbeiten es kommt mir so vor
als würden wir das ein bisschen vor uns
herschieben und das macht mir halt schon
ist zu passiv also ich bei aller kritik
auch für tempo glaube ich schon dass wir
nicht das nicht vor uns herschieben
sondern dass wir eine sehr entschlossene
bundesregierung erleben die entschlossen
handelt die auch über die parteigrenzen
hinweg über die eigene programmatik
springt und ganz klar die themen die
jetzt von dringlichkeit sind er ständig
andere den ausgaben für die
bundesratswahl stehe ich finde auch da
hätte ich ja auch bei der frage der der
energiepreise auch bei der frage der
benzinpreise bei all den fragen die die
lebenswirklichkeit betreffen schnell
antworten und lösungen zu geben und
dennoch hat er recht wenn er sagt es
gibt viel zu viele funktionäre die an
dieser stelle pauschal immer mehr und
absoluter fordern aber diejenigen die
wirklich den gürtel schon auf der
letzten loch schnalle tragen um die ist
es geht es doch letztlich auch zu
kümmern und das muss passieren das muss
politisch passieren und deshalb ärgern
auch die haltungsnoten gerade von cdu
und csu politikern die jahrelang in
verantwortung waren gerade wenn es um
die verteidigungspolitik ging und die
frage wie wir unsere bundeswehr
aufstellen dann frage ich mich schon wer
hat da verantwortung getragen und
deshalb ist es besser mein appell nicht
zurück zu schauen sondern gemeinsam nach
vorne zu schauen und lösungen anzubieten
wichtig ist auch mal zurück zu schauen
und zu gucken ok haben wir den
frühzeitig gar nicht haben wir genug gar
nicht oder schönes herr bosbach hat
heute eine these mitgebracht wo wir auch
ein bischen zurückschauen werden
ja bitte gestatten sie noch eine kurze
zwischen bemerken wollen ich sehr über
das interview nicht sehen konnte ich bin
jetzt hier in kassel ich war drei
stunden auf der autobahn
aber was ich schon seit längeren
längerer zeit seit vielen vielen wochen
bewundern sowohl wladimir klitschko also
auch seinem bruder wittern die sind ja
weltbekannte sportlern die haben auch in
ihrer zeit sehr sehr viel geld verdient
wir haben so viel geld verdienen die
könnten jetzt ganz woanders sein
irgendwo unter palmen an einem ganz ganz
sicheren ort und sie bleiben in ihrem
land und das ist sie auch motivation für
die gesamte bevölkerung da kann ich nur
sagen ein riesengroßes kompliment an
beide dass sie sich in die erste reihe
stellen und sagen wir wollen nicht unser
land russland überlassen deswegen ärgere
ich mich auch zum beispiel ich schätze
ihn ansonsten sehr sein kluger kopf
richard david precht einig der ukraine
helfen von etwas leben wie kommen wir
dazu aus der warmen stube denen die um
ihr leben
kämpfen vorzuschreiben was sie zu denken
und zu tun haben ja blick zurück ich
finde wir sind alle alle doch ziemlich
überrascht gewesen über den angriff
putins auf die ukraine am 24 februar und
ich frage mich ob sich das nicht schon
längere zeit abgezeichnet hat ob wir
nicht zu blauäugig waren unterdrückung
der opposition das war doch bekannt
politische prozesse gegen regimekritiker
mit drakonischen strafen das war doch
begann der fall litwinenko der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte an festgestellt dahinter
steht die russische regierung das
russische regie und 1000 euro
schmerzensgeld sollten an die witwe
gezahlt werden die annexion der krim
gute haben wie begründet und haben
gesagt geht eigentlich nicht das ist
völkerrechtswidrig
einmal im dom bass unterstützt um
militärische unterstützung der
separatisten wir haben nicht die
notwendigen konsequenzen gezogen und das
wird in putin zu den eindruck erweckt
haben auch jetzt beim angriff auf die
ukraine wird der westen nicht so hart
reagieren wie ich das möglicherweise
befürchtet deswegen hat er ist riskiert
ja wir brauchen gute verlässliche
stabile beziehung zu russland ja das
stimmt aber wir brauchen nicht nur
sicherheitspartnerschaft mit russland
wir brauchen auch sicherheit vor
russland wo steht eigentlich geschrieben
dass putin halt machen würde wenn er
sich eines tages was wir alle hoffen aus
der ukraine zurückziehen würde ich
fürchte er wird sich dann andere
nachbarn zügeln
herr zeyer die befürchtung von herr
bosbach teilen sie die dass putin nicht
mit der ukraine aufhören wird
er hat ja einige
wegmarken und punkten angesprochen
georgien 2008
krim 2014
auch hier das was wir in berlin erlebt
haben im tiergarten all das sind ja
punkte wo man möglicherweise erwartet
hätte dass man entschlossener
konsequenter handelt dass sich dinge
abgibt gerechnet haben und zu recht muss
man sich die frage stellen hat man
richtig gehandelt ja oder nein wir
dürfen aber nicht vergessen wir haben es
mit einer atommacht zu tun und das führt
eben auch dazu dass
wahrscheinlich aus diesen gründen heraus
vorsichtiger
bewertungen stattgefunden haben das will
ich an der stelle zu dem appell von
rambus bat dringend hinzufügen weil das
kann man nicht einfach beiseite wischen
und dass wir hier als weltgemeinschaft
gegen die aggression gegen diesen
aggressor gegen den angriffskrieg von
putin stehen dokumentiert 1 dass die
weltgemeinschaft geschlossen dem
widerstand leistet und ganz klar
formulierungen trifft und verabredung
jetzt auch trifft die dringend notwendig
sind
also ich muss sagen ich sehe das aber
herr boos verspricht mir da sehr aus dem
herzen ich glaube natürlich die
bedrohung durch eine atommacht eine
potenzielle bedrohung hat mit sicherheit
des handeln in die eine oder andere
richtung beeinflusst dennoch glaube ich
dass wir zum teil naiv an das wäre
blauäugig waren wir haben einen ex
kanzler hier in deutschland der begibt
sich mehr oder weniger in putins hände
der boss von gerd schröder ist vladimir
putin erarbeitet er bekommt geld für ihn
dass das überhaupt passiert und sich
daran im übrigen auch bis zum heutigen
tage gar nichts geändert hat ist für
mich auch ein zeichen ist für mich
sinnbildlich dafür wie wir mit dieser
großmacht umgegangen sind welches
vertrauen wir geschenkt haben sie
blauäugig wir gegangen sind weiß ich
welche aktionen welche handlungsweisen
man hätte anders machen können dass maße
ich mir nicht an zu beantworten ich
fürchte aber ich würde auf ihre antwort
dann doch noch eine schippe
blauäugigkeit und avid packen aber jetzt
stellen sie sich mal die situation von
vor die wir erlebt haben robert habeck
der jetzt gerade auf energie
einkaufstour ist und bilder die wir aus
saudi arabien gesehen haben und
dergleichen wären denn die vor jahren
bewertet worden ich glaube wir müssen
uns das gesamte die gesamte lage
anschauen und nochmal mein appell ist
jetzt nicht zurück zu schauen sondern in
aller deutlichkeit zurück dass das was
jetzt passiert anzuerkennen dass jetzt
die weltgemeinschaft geschlossen steht
dass man sich mit diesen fragen
entschlossen auseinandersetzt dass es
ein
weckruf auch für die nato gibt dass man
sich den zielen verpflichtet auch in
dieses bündnis zu investieren das sind
doch jetzt die dinge die ziemlich laufen
zwischen hertha erlauben sind die frage
an der stelle in solch heiklen
situationen wie viel zeit darf man sich
aber erlauben weil es ist ja nicht nur
ein wettkampf gegen putin sondern
irgendwo ist es ja dann auch ein
wettkampf gegen die zeit
wissen sie ich bin verantwortlich hier
in berlin für die themen im berliner
parlament fürs abgeordnetenhaus bin ich
mitglied des deutschen bundestages ich
kann ihnen aber eins sagen aus der
systematik die politik arbeitet dass
politik auch krisen modus kann und vor
allen dingen in der lage ist gerade wenn
herausforderung groß sind auch schnell
entschlossen zu handeln das haben wir zu
beginn der pandemie erlebt das haben wir
jetzt erlebt als die die der
angriffskrieg von putin in der ukraine
begann und deshalb habe ich einen grund
vertrauen in die politik weil ich sie
von innen kennen und weiß auf der brust
kann das bestätigen dass in solchen
fällen entschlossen gehandelt wird das
ist schön ich habe das grundvertrauen
nicht mehr als bürgerin also die korona
pandemie als mehr genommen jetzt muss
ich auch ehrlich sagen mit blick auf den
ukrainer krieg das so lange die politik
blogs oder nochmal genommen da würde ich
gerne eine frage an herrn bosbach
stellen und zwar ist meine frage war
rons heimat hier ein
untersuchungsausschuss gefordert am
dienstag hat ein untersuchungsausschuss
gefordert damit einfach auch mal
überprüft wie es eigentlich sein konnte
dass so viele politiker so lange für
putin war oder vielleicht auch mal eine
untersuchung wie viel habe viel
gearbeitet
was halten sie denn von so etwas herr
bosbach
davon hatte ich abstand denn das ist
nicht die aufgabe von parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschüssen breit
parlamentariern oder
regierungsmitglieder nachzuforschen
warum sie welche haltung eingenommen
haben das ist eher aufgabe von
journalist parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschüsse sollen skandal
aufklären eklatantes fehlverhalten
nehmen sie mal anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz hätte er sich
verhindern lassen können nsu gibt es
mehrere untersuchungsausschüsse
das macht sinn auch um die frage zu
beantworten wie kann man zukünftiges
verhindern dass so etwas nicht noch
einmal wiederholt müssen wir das recht
ändern brauchen wir mehr personal
bessere ausbildung und so das sind die
fragen mit denen sie
untersuchungsausschuss beschäftigen aber
doch nicht mit der motivation von denen
die öffentliche verantwortung tragen ich
würde mal jetzt als journalist würde ich
da mal anfangen bei einigen nicht bahnen
aber einigen kollegen in der kfd die
sich auch im deutschen bundestag
aufhören als wären sie die
pressesprecher der roten armee
anfang zu recherchieren
bist du das mit
der bahn in die mangel zu nehmen aber
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss gibt dann wird
der abgeordnete eingeladen und haben bis
er die frage beantworten wie kommen sie
eigentlich dazu so was kann ich mir
nicht vor es gibt da klare formalien
airbus bach hat darauf hingewiesen ist
erfahrene parlamentarier und ich glaube
dem muss man folgen dem argument auch
wenn ich emotional das verstehe aber was
mich so ein bisschen stört an dieser
debatte und dann bin ich selber naja ist
dieses zurückblicken ich glaube es gibt
viele die auch für sich zu recht in
anspruch nehmen können zu sagen haben
darauf hingewiesen wir haben in
kommentaren und sonstwo sehr früh davor
gewann auch mal zb paul ronzheimer wie
ich auch nicht immer ein fester mit
allem aber man muss das anerkennen was
er da leistet ist groß großartig und
setzt sich da jeden tag wirklich großen
gefahren aus und das ist dass es
das ist wirklich eine große reporter
leistung absolut
aber viele sind jetzt so superschlau
nicht und sagen die natürlich alle
geschwiegen haben damals inklusive
lieber bosbach sie aus der cdu weil
natürlich waren es 15 jahre lang auch
unter angela merkel die gesagt haben das
ist ein rein wirtschaftliches projekt
unter anderem nach dem 2 und nichts
dagegen getan haben wobei man auch
angela merkel zu gute halten muss dass
sie sehr klar war in der abgrenzung zum
vladimir putin dass sie da ja wie soll
ich sagen ihre frau gestanden hat wir
haben alle die bilder vor augen also sie
jetzt dhabis friedrich merz gemacht hat
in bausch und bogen zu verdammen finde
ich auch ungerecht im übrigen friedrich
merz der sich ja noch vor kurzem gegen
die einführung gegen die ablösung von
swift ausgesprochen hat der im
deutschlandfunk ich glaube vor zwei
monaten gesagt haben wir haben putin die
hand ausgestreckt 2001 im deutschen
bundestag und ich bin sehr erbost
darüber dass ist wie sie ihm damals
nicht tatsächlich auch weiter noch
gereicht haben das war muss man zusehen
muss man dazu sagen bevor überhaupt klar
wurde dass wladimir putin sich viele
menschen nicht vorhaben vorstellen
können dass russland eben diesen
angriffskrieg auch wirklich durch führt
aber dazu gehört auch wir jetzt so
schlau tut der muss sich auch messen
lassen an dem was er entweder
mitgetragen hat toleriert hat oder auch
propagiert hat in all den jahren die vor
diesen heutigen abend sind
ich habe nach vorhin großen wert darauf
gelegt ich habe von uns angesprochen ich
habe die regierung überhaupt keinen
vorwurf gemacht auch der jetzt
amtierende nicht wie komme ich dazu ich
kann wie ich nicht an debatten im
deutschen bundestag erinnern ein
gesellschaftlicher debatten an große
medien beiträge in denen wörtlich oder
sinngemäß zu hören oder zu lesen war
achtung
die gefahr die jetzt von russland
auszugehen scheint ist nicht nur latent
die kann auch sehr rasch in militärische
gewalt gegenüber nachbarn umschlagen wir
müssen die russlandpolitik ändert ich
habe das nicht mitbekommen dass ich sehr
gut noch im kopf dort trieben zwei dass
andere länder europas gesagt haben nein
nicht diese pipeline aber dass die
damalige bundesregierung unter
verantwortung der union an diesem
projekt festgehalten hat mir geht es
doch nicht um vergangenheitsbewältigung
sondern mir geht es um rückschlüsse für
die zukunft
dass khedira in der politiker was jetzt
kommt wehret den anfängen
wie können wir verhindern dass
totalitärer autoritäre staaten nicht nur
das eigene volk und die opposition
unterdrücken und bürgerrechte außer
kraft setzen sondern auch angela sie
werden gegenüber ihren nachbarn in der
zukunft mit diesem plädoyer herr bosbach
gegen eine ganz kurze unterbrechung und
gleich sind wir mit innenpolitischen
themen für sie zurück
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück meine damen
und herren bei viertel nach acht stellen
dass sie dabei sind dabei geblieben sind
nach der kurzen unterbrechung und jetzt
geht es direkt weiter mit béla anda und
der hat sich über karl lauterbach
geärgert ja und das ist nicht so einfach
heute hier nach diesen nach diesen
anderen themen am anfang zu den übergang
zu schaffen aber ich mache es trotzdem
mal ja ich habe mich heute auf gericht
über karl lauterbach unseren
gesundheitsminister den lauterbach würde
jetzt millionen deutschen eine vierte
impfung verabreichen also allen den über
60 weil er sagt das hilft super gegen
korona und das würden neueste studien
aus israel belegen aus israel wer kann
dem noch widersprechen gott sei dank
gibt es das ja alles im internet und
guckt man sich das mal etwas genauer an
dann sieht man dass diese studien auch
aus israel sehr scharf kritisiert werden
weil die sagen das hilft gar nicht gegen
die korona infektion und auch nicht
gegen eine omikron infektion auch nicht
bei denen die über 60 sind und die new
york times ja eine der angesehensten
zeitungen der welt hat heute ebenfalls
darauf hingewiesen dass es gerade bei
dieser israelischen studie die von karl
lauterbach angebracht wird und
hervorgehoben wird schwere methodische
fehler gibt auch das ist nachzulesen nun
ist ja nicht ungewöhnlich dass es bei
verschiedenen wissenschaftlichen studien
auf verschiedene meinungen gibt auch bei
wissenschaftlern
ungewöhnlich ist es aber wenn der
minister der sich um unsere gesundheit
kümmern soll die die kritik an seinen
thesen gar nicht zulässt sie auch nicht
erwähnt oder wenn überhaupt in abrede
stellt so wie er es gemacht hat mit
einem wissenschaftler der von bild
zitiert worden dies so gesagt hat nur
durst ist ja so wie der song pauli der
wissenschaft aber mein freund christian
drosten das ist der fc bayern
wahrscheinlich hat er nicht gewusst des
fc st pauli bald auch steigt in die
erste liga wahrscheinlich und das dem
verein ganz viele herzen zu gewendet
sind ich finde das was karl lauterbach
mittlerweile zeigt mit seiner
ausgrenzung von andersdenkenden ist eine
beispiellose arroganz es ist die
arroganz eines mittlerweile völlig wirr
wirkenden ministers der im lichte des
eigenen scheinwerferlicht der dem haus
studios immer wieder neue ideen sucht um
in diesen talkshows zu bestehen die aber
nichts mit der realität zu tun haben das
schlimme ist aber karl lauterbach ist
kein einfacher wirrkopf er ist ein
minister wirkt ob und ich finde würde
menschen sollten nicht an der spitze von
ministerien stehen
ich finde wir sollten mehr gelassenheit
haben vor allen dingen deshalb weil
diese ja nicht tut mir leid
ich merke dass aber diese regierung hat
einen großen schritt gemacht indem das
infektionsschutzgesetz novelliert wurde
in dem wir jetzt zurückfinden zur
normalität in dem jetzt ab dem 12 april
auch die übergangsfristen die gesetzt
wurden auslaufen und wir damit
tatsächlich wieder die normalität stück
für stück in verantwortung zurück
bekommen und dann sagen sie doch dass er
da ist halt ich stehe ich ihnen auch zu
das ist die fdp da kann man sagen bravo
die das vorangetrieben hat das können
sie sich mit ihrer partei auf die fahne
schreiben aber das hat doch nichts zu
tun mit dem verantwortlichen wirken von
herrn lauterbach die impfpflicht für uns
alle noch immer durchsetzen also ich
sage wer normalität will der sollte sich
besser impfen und das kann jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden auch das ist im
übrigen ergebnis der politischen debatte
im deutschen bundestag
dass wir keine im pflicht im augenblick
hier haben ja sie müssen nicht so
zurückkommen zu sagen dass daher ihr
verdienst und ja ich will ja nur sagen
jetzt immer auf dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium zu prügeln
kammer machen ich sage nur wir sollten
uns lieber mit der frage
auseinandersetzen wie bereiten wir uns
auf den herbst vor dazu will ich
beiträge hören und wenn eine vierte mal
kurz nach wenn alles für tabak für einen
gesundheitsminister der kompetent ist
der das beste für dieses land fällt und
sie würden sagen gut dass herr
lauterbach gesundheitsminister ist ich
glaube dass wir in sich eine gute
regierung haben die
wir reden nicht über die fdp wir reden
nicht nur die regierung störte
alarmismus von herrn lauterbach wer
stört mich aber die frage ob wir jetzt
eine vierte impfung brauchen die einen
selbst schützt
und welchen beitrag sie leisten kann die
müssen wir doch offen diskutieren gerade
wenn wir mal in diesem land vor der
welle sein wollen und nicht hinter der
welle und da muss man natürlich auch
andere studien zu lassen da gebe ich
ihnen völlig recht dass dem punkt wo ich
ihn recht gebe ich glaube aber dennoch
sollten wir jetzt mal anerkennen dass
wir den weg in die normalität
zurückfinden und weniger alarmismus man
aber dennoch erscheint muss ich als
bürger sagen genau wie nichts gesagt hat
man verliert er trotzdem die das
vertrauen in die regierung vor allem
auch das vertrauen in herrn lauterbach
wenn jede woche etwas neues gesagt wird
wenn sie eine gewisse konsequenz auch da
ist in dem was gesagt wird in dem was
gefordert wird in dem was empfohlen wird
dann verliert man das vertrauen und dann
fragt man sich schon okay was kann man
jetzt glauben was kann man nicht glauben
und was ist richtig und was ist nicht
richtig kennt jetzt einfach sagen hören
7 nicht mehr zu warten
die beschlüsse der regierung die
abgewogen aus stimmen der spd der grünen
und der fdp
abgestimmt ein lösungsvorschlag in
ordnung auf jeden fall schon mal der
diplomat der runde den titel vielleicht
ihn jetzt aber jetzt kommen wir doch mal
zu herrn bosbach und schauen mal ob herr
bosbach außerdem plomer tisch mit herr
lauterbach ist
nein kann ich nicht sein
tut mir schon fast leid dass ich das
sagen muss ich kann ihm mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr ernst nehmen er ist ja
einige monate gut über die runden
gekommen und mit dem standard vokabular
neueste studien aus harvard exzellente
fachleute wenn ich alle persönlich und
er hat an den eindruck einer
überragenden kompetenz vermittelt und da
waren ja viele froh endlich einer der
nicht nur gesundheitspolitik macht
sondern der auch mediziner ist und der
richtig ahnung vom thema hat klammer auf
im gegensatz zum damaligen amtsinhaber
jens spahn klammer zu dann gab es für
mich ein wirkliches erlebnis nämlich
karl lauterbach bekam im zdf
morgenmagazin
wie im leben nicht mitgerechnet ein paar
kritische fragen gestellt nämlich aber
nicht zu oft an am ismus verbreiten
würde daraufhin lauterbach das war so
vor 23 monaten das ist die kampagne der
bild zeitung daraufhin habe ich mir mein
tempel für schnappt und habe nur zwei
wörter
eingetippt lauterbach warnt und dann
klopfte es an allen ich habe fast ein
kabelbrand bekommen dann in tritt es
gibt 50 60 fälle vor denen lauterbach
gewarnt hat dann haben wir etwas anderes
gemacht ich hab mal die diagnose und
prognosen von klaus stöhr von hendrik
strikt daneben gelegt die waren viel
genauer als das was uns karl lauterbach
erzählt aber eins wackler lädst du
lauterbach in eine sendung an hast du am
nächsten tag eine fette schlagzeile weil
er mit sicherheit wieder vor irgendetwas
warnen wird dann hat er noch am rande
oster vergangenen jahres die spanischen
ärzte und virologen man mal eben für
komplette unkundig erklärt die zahl
würde er überhaupt nicht glauben da
würde nur beschummelt warum ist
gesundheitsminister geworden weil er zu
den bekanntesten populärsten politik und
gehört das stimmt weil ich bin sozusagen
das votum der fernsehzuschauer ins
gesundheitsministerium getragen hat es
hat schon seinen grund warum karl
lauterbach nie eine regierung er hatte
und wenn er meint das soll jetzt die
lösung ich bin einer der kandidaten
nicht nur weil ich über 60 bin sondern
wenige tage werde ich als die passion
lieber karl lauterbach nach zwei jahren
bin ich erkrankt einen monat nach meiner
vierten impfung luca mama ich bin ich
bin viermal geben so kann man natürlich
sagen ja es war kein schwerer verlauf
was auch stimmt klammer auf gottseidank
klammer zu aber so zu tun
ich habe immer im funk verstanden
sterile immunität wenn du dich dagegen
impfen lässt dann kannst du nicht mehr
daran erkranken jedenfalls im regelfall
das stimmt schon lange nicht
herr bosbach ich glaube sie haben also
alle sitzen jetzt bestimmt herrscher
ähnlich wahrscheinlich auch schon
infrage ich glaube wächst vor lars
lagerbäck ich glaube darüber dass ein
bus bach meine these einfach nur noch
mal unterstrichen hat wenn normalität
will sollte sich besser impfen ganz
einfach
noch mal unterstrichen indem er gesagt
hat er hat verloren
meinrad schade ja recht ob ich im kampf
gegen das war ein gegner eines impfzwang
ist ja dass teile ich das für die leute
war teilen sie auch was herr bosbach
gesagt hat den impfzwang
und wir sind natürlich so weit dass wir
jetzt mittlerweile uns einmal
auseinandersetzen müssen mit der drosten
regel die ja sagt am besten schütze ich
mich wenn nach drei mal geimpft bin und
drei mal infiziert am besten schwer dann
bin ich wahrscheinlich so drosten
originalton für mehrere jahre gut
geschützt was das jetzt mit der vierten
impfungen bedeutet ob ich mich jetzt
auch noch danach nach osten ein viertes
mal infizieren muss auch am besten am
besten schwer um dann für mehrere jahre
geschützt zu sein weiß ich nicht ich
kann nur sagen
lauterbach und sein haus sollte sich mal
intensiv auseinandersetzen mit den
kritischen studien sie sollten den mut
haben diese kritischen studien auch zu
der vierten impfung zu besprechen zu
bewerten und die menschen zu sagen was
es damit auf sich hat denn in diesen new
york times ist ja auch jetzt nicht sein
pauli nachrichten und man mit lauterbach
zu sprechen der solche kritischen
studien ja immer nur verunglimpft dann
auch das steht ganz klar drin dass die
über 60 in der regel nichts davon haben
und ich finde es einfach unredlich wenn
man solche kritik ausblendet sie wie den
virologen der wie gesagt von bild.de
zitiert worden ist verächtlich macht nur
weil ihm nur weil einem die meinung
nicht passt das ist kann man vielleicht
machen als abgeordneter in talkshows
aber nicht mehr als minister wir
überlassen der schlusswertung jetzt
deine these bela und kommen zur
valentina maceri die nicht kalbach
interessiert sondern das thema
gleichberechtigung und quoten das thema
gleichberechtigung und quoten ich
spreche jetzt hier mal das eis von krieg
zu corona zum thema gleichberechtigung
und quoten man hat ja immer über die
gleichberechtigung in der industrie ich
persönlich bin jeweilige fußballerinnen
und aktuelle sportjournalistin und sport
moderatorin und sage im sport 1 voran im
fußball ist es noch viel schlimmer denn
2 prozent nur der geschäftsführenden der
bundesliga-vereine sind tatsächlich
weiblich anfang 22 lag der frauenanteil
in den vorständen der dax-unternehmen
bei
18,1 und im fußball liegt der anteil an
frauen die in den führungspositionen
arbeiten gerade mal bei zwei prozent das
ruft natürlich jetzt alle freunde der
frauenquote hier auf den plan dennoch
sage ich bitte nicht keine frauenquote
quote wir brauchen mehr frauen mit eiern
heißt mehr frauen die tatsächlich diesen
sport lieben die auch etwas verändern
wollen und nicht frauen die einfach auf
diese positionen gesetzt werden weil es
eine quote gibt wir könnten ja auch
unfähige männer die mit sicherheit auf
diesen positionen sitzen zunächst mit
einem vielleicht bisschen fähigeren
frauen besitzen ich bin ganz ganz großer
fan der pute ich glaube auch nicht dass
wir eine brauchen ich glaube dass wir
all diese frauen haben die diese jobs
können die lust auf diese jobs haben und
warum kommen sie nicht auf diese jobs
weil sie verhindert werden und ich
wünschte wir bräuchten keine quote ich
würde auch wieder das würde sich
regulieren oder schauen wir auf die
letzten 50 jahre und wenn du die zahlen
1 2 prozent in führungspositionen beim
bonner ist nicht ganz der ganze sport
das muss man der dazu sagen derzeit weit
über noch mal separat zu betrachten der
fußball ist in der ganzen sport bei noch
einmal speziell zu betrachten dennoch
sage ich oder ist meine vermutung es
gibt tatsächlich auch nicht so viele
frauen die das unbedingt wollen genauso
sehr wie vielleicht ein mann die dann
auch den mut haben das laut
auszusprechen und das ist leider auch
unsere geschichte geschuldet weil wir
frauen generell so erzogen wurden
niemals zu laut zu sein niemals zu
fordernd zu sein das schiff gegangen
ich kenne ein paar bau hat er ganz toll
gemacht aber das brauchen wir ja auch
also genau solche frauen brauchen wir im
fußball wir brauchen frauen die den
fußball lieben die diesen sport lieben
die da auch etwas bewegen wollen die die
frauen auch nach vorne bringen wollen
und sie sich dann auch dafür einsetzen
und bitte nicht frauen die auf
positionen gesetzt werden nur aufgrund
der quote weil damit tut man uns frauen
keinen gefallen und der fußball ist
komplex und da braucht es definitiv
kompetente leute definitiv auch
kompetente frauen die muss man finden
aber ich sage es gibt noch nicht so
viele solche argumentation der ich sonst
nur von weißen alten männern damit seine
argumentation die mich wahnsinnig
überrascht aus dem mund einer frau denn
natürlich gibt es diese frauen noch mal
und zwar in allen bereichen das ist das
klassische argument das klassische
fahrzeuge macho argument dass man dann
also ist eine eigene mostereien geburt
würdest du die quote ansetzen weil das
ist immer ganz sparen also würde deine
frau wurde beginnen welche kanäle so gar
nicht genau sagen ich bin da keine
rächenden mensch der jetzt ausrechnen
könnte wie mir ist einfach nur wichtig
dass wir es festsetzen dass wir uns
in diese positionen bringen denn ich
glaube und da geht es eben um diese
freiwilligkeit und die müssen wir suchen
und so werden wir frauen inszeniert am
und selbst wenn du gar nicht die beste
frau hasst für die position dann kannst
du damit rechnen dass andere frauen nach
aber darin die riesige bühne live wir
holen wenn das hier eröffnen wir nehmen
die gleich bei drei oder vier tagen
immer wieder einmal fürchterlich
patricia diesen das mittel passe ich
richtig deswegen frage ich es lieber
einen alten weisen mann und zwei rosbach
ich hoffe es ist in ordnung der
sichtweise bezeichnete für mich in der
weise ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen
wie sie denn zu dem thema stehen
da ganz so als manu fehler machen am
besten im
kopf zwischen die schultern und sagt ich
habe keinen empfang im moment ist und
gestern satz gehört wenn ich sie kurz
unterbrechen darf heutzutage ist es auch
nicht leicht ein mann zu sein es stimmt
ja anscheinend
ja ich hätte es nicht besser sagen
können dürfte ja bekannt dafür sich zu
hause mit fünf frauen zusammenleben ist
nicht einfach aber es geht
ich meine beleben berechtigt wenn man
sich die runde hier anschaut dann weiß
jeder kommentar ist besetzt
natürlich sagt hier geht das ist ein
überfall geworden wurde
wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe
christian seifert der hat ja wirklich
aus der dfl was gemacht hat den dienst
quittiert und ich glaube er hat eine
nachfolgerin wenn ich richtig informiert
bin
auch für hopfen genau aber sie ist doch
garantiert nicht an die spitze der dfl
gekommen weil sie jetzt eine quote
erfüllen muss weil die nächste besetzung
eine frau sein muss sondern weil sie
einfach gut ist und genau ich bin kein
anhänger bin kein anhänger der kot und
ich glaube es ist eine frage der zeit es
ist eine frage der zeit wenn er das es
als ganz selbstverständlich angesehen
wird dass auch führungsposition im sport
im männerdominierten
fußballsport
ganz ganz selbstverständlich
spitzenpositionen entscheidung eine
frage der zeit wie viele jahre sollen
wir denn da noch warten also noch mal 50
jahre ist es ja nicht so dass ich so
wahnsinnig viel bewegt hat in den
vergangenen jahren ist wenn ich jetzt
gerne aus leiten wir können ja mal zum
amerikanischen fußballverband schauen er
hat der jüngste gerade gesagt dass auch
die preisgelder
angehoben werden sollen und ich finde
schon dass es gut wäre die preisgelder
im frauenfußball genauso hoch anzusetzen
wie im männerfußball
das wäre für mich gelebte
gleichberechtigung
wir sollten uns dafür einsetzen ja sei
eben an dieser stelle auch für gute
hochwertige trainingsbedingungen all das
was dazu gehört gibt dann brauchen dann
nämlich auch diese quotendiskussion
nicht dann kann er hier bleiben und muss
nicht den fußball zur
[Gelächter]
seite sprung zur seite springen daten
nicht ich komme ja aus berg schlagbaren
ich war jahrelang im präsidium von ssg
und wir hatten ja deutschlands
erfolgreichste fußball frauenmannschaft
über jahre hinweg zunächst war der
frauenfußball verboten
dann wurde er erlaubt und dann suchte
man eine nationalmannschaft und da hat
man unsere mannschaft aus bergisch
gladbach in nationaltrikots gesteckt
nach taiwan geschickt und wir haben
sogar zweimal den weltpokal gewonnen als
dann die richtige deutsche
nationalmannschaft der frauen an den
start ging mit acht oder neun
spielerinnen aus berg geschafft hat das
erste tor wurde von einer nachbarin
geschossen von loris krise wurden die
wohnte bei uns um die ecke um gab es ein
café sowie als preis
die zeit da hat sich werden aber es
stimmt es gibt immer noch eine grosse
differenz
madrid gegen barcelona wurde der
zuschauer rekord gebrochen bei den
frauen ist waren über 91.000 zuschauern
stadion und das zeigt es bewegt sich
definitiv etwas auch im fußball und es
geht auch ohne quote und ohne zwang
regeln das was er bosbach sagt das habe
ich mal nachgeguckt das war 1989 das war
ein kaffeeservice mit blauen und roten
blüten wie die spielerinnen bekommen
fortschrittlich damit erlaubt aber wenn
wir uns angucken deswegen bin ich auch
bei meinen beiden männlichen kollegen
wir sind alle dafür dass die zahlungen
ich weiß nicht wer realistisch das ist
aber angeglichen werden die letzte
statistik die ich davon gefunden habt
stammt das im jahr 2018 das dann dass
eine frau im profifußball in der ersten
liga im durchschnitt
39.000 euro im jahr verdient das
verdient ein bundesliga-spieler im
durchschnitt an einem spieltag
gelungen war auch nicht frei
wirtschaften sich eine revanche du
liebst doch auch die freie wirtschaft
würde ich jetzt mal absolut das heißt es
ja auch angebot und nachfrage
das heißt ich könnte jetzt mal patricia
fragen als frauenquote für den sport
fussball wie oft schaust du den
frauenfußball ich muss sagen ich schau
frauen wo es beim männerfußball aber
schon und dementsprechend angebot und
nachfrage wo es dann nicht erst mal um
auch das geld zu zahlen für gehälter für
preise da muss doch erst mal das
interesse am frauenfußball hoch sein ist
auch wie in einem im leben angebot und
nachfrage
vielleicht weniger in den gremien wären
finden sie wege den frauenfußball auch
so zu erziehen dass er auch häufiger
gesendet wird formen zu finden wo man
sagt okay das schaue ich mir an aber
wenn du eine riege da ist dass wir jetzt
mal gegen mein geschlecht die sagten
interessiert uns nicht oder nur pro
forma dann komme ich ja auch nicht da
hin dass zu entwickeln also das finde
ich ein ganz wichtigen hinweis und das
ist das warum wir euch männer darin
brauchen auch damit ihr
gemeinsam auch öffnen kann und deswegen
auch total schade dass hier so wenige
männer ihres gerade in dieser diskussion
zu wort kommen dabei sagt wähler genau
das
zu erlernen wir lassen euch mehr zeit
zum reden aber das ist genau das was ich
das selbst entwickelt dass man schaut je
mehr wir frauen auch in solche
positionen bringen desto mehr frauen
werden nach brasilien aber man darf man
darauf sein held für das thema von herta
gab
abschließend sagen man muss ja das
problem an der wurzel packt man muss die
wurzel ausreißen dafür braucht man auch
die männer dafür braucht man keine quote
denn wenn man nur die blätter rausreißt
und das wäre die quote dann wachsen dir
immer wieder nach was physisch ist
valentina einen löwen sternzeichen löwe
sich direkt das schlusswort geholt sehr
gut jetzt waren wir weiter mit herrscher
ja und nicht über gleichberechtigung
obwohl sie merken bett bild wird die
särge lebt ja wir haben ja sogar nach
parität heute beseitig erlebe sogar hier
viel pragmatismus und diesen
pragmatismus den würde ich mir wünschen
wenn es um unsere infrastrukturprojekte
in deutschland geht wir haben jetzt
jungs gerade erlebt mit der umsetzung
des
bundesverkehrswegeplans zur
zum weiterbau der a100 hier in der
hauptstadt in berlin großen widerstand
der grünen die auf der einen seite das
im deutschen bundestag mitgetragen habe
auf der anderen seite in berlin kein
mieter diese autobahn wollen wer die
zukunft gestalten will der braucht eine
funktionierende verkehrsinfrastruktur
denn wasserstoff antriebe und
elektroantriebe brauchen genau das auch
und darüber hinaus auch heute die
diskussion um die frage der ukraine und
die versorgungsengpässe die uns
bevorstehen möglicherweise fordern uns
gerade wenn es um trassen bauten geht
wie den süd link deshalb mein dringender
appell mehr pragmatismus um die
großprojekte in deutschland
voranzubringen denn es ist dringender
denn je
hat ja recht aber ehrlich gesagt ja ich
kann es nicht mehr hören weil das sagen
wir jetzt seit 20 jahren das hat mir
gesagt als ich
regierungssprecher der rot grünen
bundesregierung war es gibt immer wieder
irgend jemand der sich um
bürokratieabbau kümmert irgendjemand der
sachen schneller machen wollen ich saß
im transrapid in shanghai als der eine
technologie die wir abgeschafft haben
schnurgerade innerhalb von wenigen
minuten vom flughafen dann in innenstadt
rollte und das ist ja genau das problem
wir wir entwickeln unsere technik nicht
weiter wir exportieren sie dort wird sie
umgesetzt mit maßnahmen die wir gar
nicht wollen auch nicht ich meine wir
wollen auf der einen seite schnelligkeit
beim bauen wie in china auf der anderen
seite wollen wir aber immer mehr
bürgerbeteiligung bürgerfreiheit dafür
stehen sie auch tolle sache nur wie
passt das zusammen wir erleben in
sketchen wie den hafen in buchs oder wo
die lng terminals gebaut werden sollen
das kleinst tiere nicht kleintiere
sondern kleinst tiere wahrscheinlich
mikroskopisch große diesem baum
möglicherweise behindern werden weil der
bund für naturschutz sagt da ist
irgendwas im bad das muss man aber
schützen jedes lebewesen hat schutz
verdient absolut bin ich auch für nur
diese dualität und sich dann hin zu
stellen zu sagen ja wir brauchen ein
bisschen mehr schnelligkeit das ist
wichtig das ist sehr wohlfeil im übrigen
noch mal zu ihrem autobahn projekt das
auch sehr ungewöhnlich zumindest das
verfahren was ich gelesen habe denn das
war offenkundig nicht vom minister mit
der landesregierung abgestimmt oder
abgesprochen schon die auch einen
bundesverkehrswegeplan dann hätten wir
aus seiner riesen können es richtig
normalerweise redet miteinander ich
finde das ist eine debatte die ich will
gar nicht führen aber es ist recht
wohlfeil sich hin zu stehen und sie
sagen wir brauchen mehr schnelligkeit
dann muss man auch sagen wie
funktioniert das mit der
bürgerbeteiligung gibt es die wie im
bisherigen maße oder gibt es sie nicht
und muss man da auch was schneller
machen das ist ja offenkundig auch dass
sie unter anderem von robert habeck ich
glaube dass bevor wir über die frage der
bürgerbeteiligung reden und glauben dass
da gebremst wird was auch wir gerade
beim südlichen thüringer erleben dass
viele bürgerinitiativen sich dagegen
stellen auf der anderen seite aber sagen
wir müssen dringend in erneuerbare
energien investieren aber bitte nicht
vor meiner haustüre die entsprechenden
baumaßnahmen dass wir uns dessen bewusst
werden müssen in unserem land dass wenn
wir uns den herausforderungen der
zukunft stellen wollen dass das für
jeden vielleicht auch persönliche
einschnitte mitbringt gerade wenn es um
solche baumaßnahmen geht temporär und
ich glaube nicht dass wir vom durch das
bautempo bestimmen lassen sollten
sondern an dieser stelle ganz klar auch
für den fortschritt und das was an
notwendigkeit ist eintreten und das ist
auch so daher gesagt jetzt ja weil
ehrlich gesagt wenn sie auf dem land
leben machen wir's mal konkret sie leben
auf dem land zu ziehen ausland raus aus
berlin haben die idylle dort auf einmal
kommt der südlich oder der not link eine
riesen trasse vor ihrer tür oder jemand
sagt ich baue mir eine windkraftanlage
gehen wo keine stehen sollte die nachts
immer schön gemacht sagen sie dann toll
für die allgemeinheit finde ich das gut
oder versuchen sie nicht vielleicht auch
zu sehen dass diese trasse paar
kilometer weiter nach süden oder nach
osten oder nach westen verschoben wird
und sagen diese windkraftanlage die soll
woanders sind also da ist sich glaube
ich immer noch jeder selbst der nächste
kommen sagt leider aber so ist es im
moment und da finde ich es einfacher es
ist so wie mit dem gürtel enger schnallt
jeder muss irgendwas tun aber aber sie
bieten auch keine lösung da ich sage es
muss dafür ein gewinner barbara dürfen
sie jetzt kommt die passage oper erzählt
vom krieg
die sich nur an früher erinnern können
wir hatten von 1991 das muss doch
einander wissen wir hatten von 1992 bis
2006 auch
wasserwege planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
wichtig wir haben alle gewusst der
gesetzgeber hat manchmal helle momente
haben alle gewusst mit dem planungsrecht
west bekommen wie die neuen bundesländer
in den nächsten jahrzehnten in der
infrastruktur nicht aufforderung an das
haben alle gewusst deswegen hat ist nur
für die neuen länder und berlin dieses
verkehrswege
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz gegeben
was überhaupt nur zwölf paragrafen hatte
und nur eine einzige
instanzen geklagt wurde kein instanzen
zug sein erster und letzter instanz
waren das bundesverwaltungsgericht in
leipzig man hätte ihr auf die idee
kommen können dieses recht auf die ganze
bundesrepublik deutschland zu übertragen
also ich bin also 99 prozent auf der
seite von herrn dreyer aber ich muss
auch er an einem punkt recht geben
sobald diese beschleunigung geht kommt
sofort die nächste frage werden hier
nicht bürger beteiligungsrechte abgebaut
ja da muss man sich entscheiden
es schneller und mehr bürgerbeteiligung
wird nicht gehen schneller und mehr
umwelt und naturschutz wird nicht gehen
und der andere hat zu recht darauf
hingewiesen wie das bei uns in
deutschland läuft in der sache selber
hat der scharia recht ist muss schneller
werden
aber diese zeit fordert uns doch
insbesondere wir können doch nicht über
die frage nachdenken wie können wir
erneuerbare energien in unserem land
schneller aufbauen und fokussieren und
auf der anderen seite schaffen wir nicht
die entsprechenden voraussetzungen dafür
zu schaffen und das ist mein appell dass
es uns alle fordern wird und das bringt
uns vielleicht zum will die moderation
nicht übernehmen aber vielleicht sogar
mit dem feld
von wladimir klitschko gehört haben dass
es uns eben alle betrifft und uns
betrifft es hier ziemlich direkt in
diesen fragen die wir jetzt auch angeben
der ausgang der sendung ist noch nicht
ganz da also habe ich noch zeit ihn eine
rückfrage zu stellen und diese rückfrage
ist ja wir wollen es schneller machen
und auch bo kratie natürlich abbauen
aber ist die bürokratie nicht vielleicht
auch ein zeichen einer gesunden
demokratie man kennt das von autoritären
staaten wo schnell auch form umgesetzt
werden können ist es nicht vielleicht
auch mit bürokratie auf den geist aber
kann sich auch ein zeichen einer
gesunden demokratie seien länger dauert
es kommt auf die geschwindigkeit an in
der tat aber ich brauche nicht jeden
verwaltungsakt drei mal
elf in der butzbacher hatten hervorgehen
die idee hier ein bestattungsgesetz
beschleunigungsgesetz und das ist das
ist im grunde die art und weise wie man
mit diesen herausforderungen umgehen
kann weil es hat ja auch zu guten
ergebnissen geführt weitestgehend
sicherlich seit 91 und vielleicht ist
jetzt die zeit dass wieder anzusetzen
zeit für ein beschleunigungsgesetz in
deutschland die zeit für ein
beschleunigungsgesetz in deutschland
damit möchten sie enden herrscher habe
ich im gefühl nein ich glaube dass wir
uns einfach
vergegenwärtigen müssen dass auch wir
auf diese neuen herausforderungen
reagieren müssen und dass wir uns auch
selber hinterfragen müssen und es auch
dazu führt dass wir selber den einen
oder anderen einschnitt erleben ja
und deshalb ist es durchaus lohnenswert
diese frage eines beschleunigungsgesetz
es in diesem land zu diskutieren
wollen wir doch damit wollte auch die
sendung beenden mit dem wunsch nach dem
beschleunigungs setzt ich sage danke an
meine gäste béla anda patricia plat hier
wolfgang bosbach sebastian czaja und
valentina maceri ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn sie nächste woche dienstag
wieder einschalten und ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen abend und bis bald
[Musik]